А щось я цього Віталіка не бачу, що він, є?
— Віталік?
— Ага.
— Це який?
— Що з батьком працював, забула прізвище...
А, він на морозиво пішов.
— Теща в Італії.
— Ааа!
Що?
У засаді сидів.
Я і в Києві трохи поробив на маршруті,
потім з Бояркою, цирк.
«Помотало» мене життя на старості років.
[голос диктора] Зупинка «Загальноосвітня школа №11».
[голос диктора] Наступна зупинка «Магазин “Валентина”».
У мене старший брат — футболіст, середній — футболіст
і я пішов цією лінією.
Був турнір у Києві, і після нього мене
мали забрати в інтернат при школі «Динамо» (Київ).
Але батьки не пустили.
Кажуть: «Вистачить. Два футболісти є, третього не треба».
А потім перекваліфікувався на мотобол.
Фортеця і мотобол.
Кам'янець знали тоді тільки завдяки
мотобольній команді і тому що тут є фортеця.
Це наш «наймолодший» тренер команди.
Володя Даниляк — 64 роки,
майстер спорту міжнародного класу.
Офіційна дата народження мотоболу у Кам'янці —
14 серпня 1966 року,
торік ми відсвяткували 50-річчя мотоболу.
Запросили мене у Керменець...
Я вже думав зав'язувати, як кажуть,
а запросили у Керменці,
щоб там почати мотобол повністю з нуля.
І пішло-пішло, і хлопчики вже.
То був 1985 рік, виграли чемпіонат України одразу.
Потім знову повернувся у Кам'янець, й так іде.
Треба більше рухів, хлопці: рух-рух-рух! Все!
Якщо вірити офіційній легенді, то вигадали французи,
а мотоциклісти вирішили пограти у  футбол на мотоциклах.
[свистить у свисток]
Тисяча миттєвостей у цьому виді спорту.
Це наша майстерня.
Тут ремонтуємо мотоцикли,
тут зимова стоянка мотоциклів,
бо мотоцикли з водяним охолодженням.
Команда з'явилася 1981 року з приходом Васильовича.
Були занепади, були сплески, було все.
Починаючи з 2007-го, не грали тільки один рік.
У 2013-му команда почала своє відродження.
Ми вирішили піти шляхом
навчання своїх гравців і молоді.
Набрали молодих гравців.
Оці хлопці, яким по 21 рік,
фактично розпочали цю команду.
Хтось відсівається, хтось приходить новий.
Щороку ми ходимо навчальними закладами,
спеціально і проводимо лекції:
розповідаємо, що таке мотобол, що можна займатися.
Від людини необхідно тільки бажання займатися.
Забезпечуємо технікою, яка вже є,
паливно-мастильні матеріали, за можливості,
форма, участь у чемпіонатах...
В Україні на сьогодні п'ять команд.
Є ще дві команди на тимчасово окупованій території:
це «Союз-3» (Єнакієво)
та «Антрацит» (Кіровське) Донецької області.
Я найстарший в Україні.
І от сьогодні потренувався, отримав такий кайф,
чесне слово! Ожив!
Мені як жінка казала,
коли мотобол було ніби прикрито,
а потім знов почали.
Говорить: «Ти аж ожив, очі у тебе почали світитися,
тож нумо займайся».